foreign
well hi everybody uh if you weren't here
on Friday when I announced and I also
announced it on the YouTube Community
Tab and on the Facebook page too
um that we decided because everybody
might be like hey it's Monday where is
The Haunting [__] I mean if anybody
cared all that much yeah but we said on
Friday it's like we were kind of getting
uh a little burned out on the haunting
shows like I said they were getting a
little bit samey and yeah it's kind of
like the same thing over there right and
then season seven is like not as good
and stuff and I was like why don't we
like just give them a break or we might
go back to them later because we still
have a bunch yeah but um I was like why
don't we just get rid of that for a
little while and then we'll just do the
movie review on Monday instead yeah and
then we can do other things on Saturday
and Sunday
plus we have to start reorganizing our
schedule and our time because of the
other stuff that we're doing yeah and um
you know we got to start prioritizing
profitability that's one thing but
a haunting we've kind of we're starting
to run that into the ground and they
just started to be kind of sound a lot
alike because it is a formulaic and they
were getting a lot less substantive like
I said like I noticed like I was
noticing I was only getting like a page
and a half of notes whereas before I'd
get like a whole like pages and pages of
notes the best haunting episodes were
the ones we don't even have the pilot
episodes
we did do shows a long time ago on both
of those but yeah but yeah so I decided
I was like well I don't want to stop
doing the movie reviews because people
seem to like those more than the
haunting shows
um and I like doing the movie reviews
also because we watch a lot of movies so
we decided to just move that to Monday
and then that's what we're gonna do for
the foreseeable future I guess why did I
pick this movie randomly I don't really
know actually I had been wanting to
re-watch this uh this is the movie
freeway from 1996 by the way which I
feel like nowadays is kind of like a big
cult classic
but it's still the kind of cult classic
that I feel like maybe a lot of people
also haven't heard of
if that makes any sense you know what I
mean so it's like a very under the radar
called classic I never heard of it yeah
well I liked it yeah it's great yeah but
the thing about it you have to go into
it okay don't just go into it looking
because the cover of it is lame like the
cover of it doesn't look like the tone
of the movie at all it just looks very
generic it looks like a generic Thriller
and it's not it's actually kind of a
black comedy
um even though I think maybe when this
first came out I don't think people
realized it was supposed to be funny
um and so maybe but it's along the same
lines I feel like it's very much along
the same lines as like a Tarantino film
or Natural Born Killers or something
like that it has like that kind of tone
to it yeah it's about this real trashy
Southern chick from Texas all right her
mom's a hooker her dad's just kind of a
worthless or a crackhead yeah her
stepdad's a crackhead is trying to
molest her I guess he does well yeah he
does not try and he does he does it and
um
she's kind of in a school for [__]
delinquents and uh or she's in
specialist yeah because she's illiterate
yeah she's illiterate and uh [__]
it's just one thing leads to another
random they're gonna send her down to a
foster home because her parents get
locked up go to prison so she's gonna
run to go see her grandmother and live
with her grandmother her grandmother
doesn't know or never met her she
doesn't even know she exists yeah
Mom's all [__] up car tries to drive
it there but I guess she sees the engine
and burnt it up
and guy comes and picks her up on the
side of the road helps her out played by
Keith Keith Sutherland yeah and he plays
this guy he seems real cool like he's a
psychologist you know or a counselor he
works with troubled boys yeah that kind
of stuff he says that but does he
actually I guess he does uh yes or he
does yeah
he gets her in the car and offs her to
take her to her grandmother's house and
real soon he just starts getting weirder
and weirder turns out he's a serial
killer yeah and that's where the trouble
starts
but this character what's her name again
Vanessa Vanessa yeah that's the
character's name yeah that's that that's
the actor it's Reese Witherspoon yeah
she's cute as a bug and this I think was
before she got super super big like in
Legally Blonde and all that I think this
is like she's young she's real cute and
the movie kind of brings back 90s
fashion how cool a lot of that 90s
fashion was it started to come back in
you can buy it from like Sheen as a
whole 90s section in a 2000 section but
she's wearing some really cool clothes
but even though she's just trashy as
hell
poor girl can't help it and she's kind
of heroic she's real brain and she
fights like [__] hell
she says crazy [__] and it's funny she
has such great lines yeah and uh she's
totally
feral you know pretty much yes she's
gets in trouble and
gets a key tries to kill the serial
killer and then the serial killer
[__] says I don't know who she is she
didn't and they didn't believe her that
she was a sir that he was a serial
killer and they they lock her up and
then she gets involved in a bunch of
prison fights and does a jailbreak and
Ellen
for Grandma's house she's still trying
to get to her Grandma's ass well yeah
and some of the girls that broke out
with her kill dudes get killed I think
they killed one of the female girls they
did yeah I think she was dead she looked
like I think so she looked pretty and uh
and then in the end she has a Big Show
Now the serial killer was waiting for
her grandma's house and it's all kind of
based around Little Red Riding hat yeah
you know and he's waiting for her
dressed up he's like in bed you know
and uh you know it's an old movie so
spoilers you know she does survive it
and and the dude and the serial killer
gets killed
but then she's they just kind of leave
it hanging you don't know what happened
to her I guess there's a sequel isn't
there there is but it's different
characters it's different character okay
uh yeah the sequel is called um freeway
too it's Confessions of a trick baby
okay no trick baby yeah yeah and I think
Jennifer Tilly is in the sequel actually
I've heard the sequel is also great but
I don't remember anything about it I did
see it but it was a long time ago and uh
just a lot of the [__] is just
stereotypical [__] Southern you know
she [__] brings up being you know
being saved and the Lord and [__] at
weird times and just it's [__] funny
you know it's kind of true to life to
like she's a delightful character I mean
she's kind of like it's very over the
top yeah like I said it's a black comedy
you have to kind of approach it as
though it's a black comedy
um but
she's really really over the top and
she's almost kind of like just skates
that thin line between like really
really grating or like really annoying
but somehow still
um she is just funny as hell in this
[__] movie I mean she's just [__]
hilarious yeah and it's it's
this this character archetype is kind of
like
stereotypical of somebody you'd see in
the South and there's truth in it but
this is like real trashy you know what I
mean like yeah it's real trashy it's
like over the top yeah yeah I know some
people's families are really like this
they really are but it's out there even
for here yeah I mean this is taking like
[__] Ricky Lake and Geraldo Rivera
and all that and just like putting it in
Jerry Springer yeah and all it's like a
Jerry Springer yeah family like come to
life like cranks up to 11. and the way
and even though she survives it you
don't know whether or not she's free
because she committed a bunch of crimes
like in the course in the courses
escaping from prison and trying to get
right at Grandma's house
and she was innocent really you know
what I mean she
the guy was a serial killer and was
trying to kill her you know which they
figured that out eventually it's like a
while but I mean obviously they didn't
believe her at first because he was like
an upstanding citizen quote unquote and
she was a juvenile delinquent with like
this big huge rap sheet for arson and
robbery and fighting and like she
committed
Escape
yeah
now if you escape from prison and the
charges ended up getting dropped because
they were false they probably can't
punish you for escape yeah because
you're like what the [__] because you
expect me to do I didn't do it to start
with but during the jailbreak some of
the other girls killed the guard and
then she herself
kidnapped a dude and put him in the
trunk of his own car I mean he didn't
die I guess but she didn't kidnap him
yeah yeah but uh and it was also kind of
like armed robbery or carjacking because
she pulled a gun on him yeah and took
his car she posed as a hooker yeah and
then stole his car
made him take his pants off put him in a
trunk
and then she drove to her Grandma's
house with him in the truck he lived as
far as we know yeah but in instead of
Louisiana or Mississippi
carjacking's about 20 years
well this all took place in California
so oh yeah I guess it was good and then
because she was going to Stockton that's
where her grandmother lived and [__]
kidnapping
and Louisiana's life Mississippi it's
probably life too you can't take anybody
anywhere without their consent under
Force
they're gonna give you life sentence for
that
that's why a lot of times that these
serial rapists abduct a woman and they
take her somewhere they usually kill her
because it's not an extra charge he's
going to do life anyway if he gets
caught so best thing to do is to kill
her that's why a lot of laws backfire
oh it's unintended consequences
shouldn't be life
should be more like 10. I mean it's well
I guess it would depend on the
circumstances yeah right because if it's
only 10 there's a better chance he'll
take the risk and not killing you and
not kill you right but if it's life and
he just he just kills you because that
way you can't testify against him
so if that's the criminal way of
thinking you know just simply just don't
think that way
but they do they don't have those same
limits that you have
but um
it's a great movie I mean I don't know
what happens to her really I guess like
I said they did make a sequel but I
think it's about a difference not a
different different person like person
it's not like nobody from the first
movie was in it yeah so yeah so what the
weird thing about this I saw this movie
back in I didn't see it in the theater
it only got like a very brief theatrical
release because I think it premiered at
Sundance
in 1996. and then it went to HBO I don't
know if it was originally made for HBO
might have been but it screened on HBO
and uh the critic response to it was so
positive that they were like oh well
maybe we should give it like a limited
theatrical release so it did get a
limited theatrical release it didn't do
all that well at the box office like I
said black comedy is kind of a hard sell
um and especially one that is as
uh rude as this one uh as ballsy as this
one as violent as this one like I said
it's very much in the vein of Natural
Born Killers which is almost kind of
like a black comedy tale so it's kind of
like that it's not quite as [__] up as
that but it's along the same lines or
it's like you know along the same lines
of like Pulp Fiction or something it
reminds me of that kind of stuff
so
um the thing so it didn't do very well
like when it with a theater but like
critics really seem to like it and over
the years it seemed to have gotten like
a a pretty substantial cult following
there were some people on Reddit that
said it was like their favorite movie
ever which is you know fair enough but I
like I said I think the problem too why
this kind of float still flies under a
lot of people's radar and even did back
in the 90s is the cover art the cover
art
is so
bad it's I mean it's just it's very very
it's not bad it's just blah it's boring
it doesn't really give you any and I
know that like a lot of movies that came
out in the 90s especially ones that were
like direct to DVD Thrillers had covers
just like that where it was like two big
huge photoshopped heads of the two main
stars and then there was like a little
Tableau down here like a car or somebody
with a gun or somebody like it right
right so they pretty much all looked
like that like back in the 90s and this
one looks like that too so it doesn't
really give you any clue as to what the
tone of the movie is like like it
doesn't even suggest that it's actually
funny because it is funny like in a
[__] up way you know what I mean
because
I had it's weird because I saw this
movie a long time ago and like I said
back in the 90s and I remembered really
liking it
but I hadn't I haven't seen it since
then and for whatever reason I've been
scrolling through and I kept seeing it
popping up like in my suggested stuff on
it's on 2B and the sequel's on there too
I think
and I was just like man I've been
meaning to like re-watch that and then
last night I was kind of scrolling
around I was like yeah we kind of need
something to talk about or whatever and
I was like man you know I think I'm
gonna pull the trigger on that because
I've been wanting to re-watch it and
literally all I've remembered about it
was the part where she gets picked up by
Kiefer Sutherland and he's a serial
killer I didn't remember and and the
thing about it is that like that's only
like the first third of the movie I had
forgotten about her going to jail
um about him surviving like getting shot
and like coming after her like I forgot
about that whole [__] other subplot
because this thing goes in like crazy
crazy directions I thought the whole
thing was I thought I remembered the
whole thing was just like a thriller
where she gets picked up by a serial
killer and it's like a cat and mouse
kind of thing you know what I mean like
The Hitcher or something right I I but
like funny because The Hitcher is
absolutely not funny but um I saw more
like a Tarantino movie that's what I'm
saying it reminds me a lot of that kind
of like sense of humor yeah like very
very
um
Politically Incorrect very very rude
very yeah because this this chick uses
racial slurs like crazy
which is yes yeah
like I said she's feral basically pretty
much yeah yeah she's just a street kid
I mean you can't really blame the poor
girl because like I said her mom who's
played by Amanda Plummer by the way so
Amanda Plummer is only in the beginning
but um the mom it it kind of cracks me
up because the mom is a hooker and she's
literally
soliciting like on the sidewalk in front
of their house yeah yeah she's and it's
like for some reason that just like
tickled the [__] out of me so it's like
oh well that's nice you don't even have
a long commute you know what I mean you
just kind of like go out of the sidewalk
in front of your house and be like hey
what a date
that's like super funny but yeah so
because she gets hauled off to the
clinic like pretty early on and then the
step dad does too and like I said they
she says later well she wasn't just
molested by the stepdad she was molested
by some of the Foster families that they
put her in because her parents have been
in and out of prison the one of the
funniest things in this and I love that
they didn't even
like really
um refer to it like in the universe of
the movie but she's talking to uh Kiefer
Sutherland's character his name is Bob
Bob Wolverton that's his name because
like I said he's big bad wolf so um so
they're like in a diner and she's like
oh that's step dad he's not my real dad
like my real dad was a Merchant Marine
or something like that she's like and I
have a picture of him she shows him a
picture of her dad and it's Richard's
friends
really what she was is she was a trip
baby
her mother just didn't tell her that she
was a trick baby that's right I ain't no
trick baby
but so well that was I mean that I think
that was one of the I like I [__]
laughed out loud when I saw that because
I was just kind of like well does that
does that apply that her dad actually
really was Richard's back or that's just
what her mom that's what her mother gave
her my mother didn't know who that was
just gave her that she was here that's
your Daddy yeah she was a trick yeah
and uh I was like laugh my ass yeah and
in the beginning you know her mom's out
tricking and [__] her stepdad's [__]
the last in there
and when she's at the at the school her
boyfriend's this black guy another
student there Chopper Chopper yeah and
we I recognize the guy but I can't place
him he's from he was in um [__] I looked
it up because he was a famous actor he's
in a [__] tournament he's in a [__] ton
of mood I was trying but I was looking
through this young in this though so
he's hard to recognized and I was and I
was like um I was trying to think he was
in um Riddick Riddick yeah that's that's
one of the and I know that you saw that
so I was kind of like well that's
probably where you're recognizing him
from he was in so he's been in a million
other things yeah that's probably he
loves the [__] out of her all right and
she's got to go back to her grandma he's
[__] heartbroken and [__] he gives
her a gun to protect herself when she
uses that later on well he also says
sell this when you get where you go like
for money yeah and then uh she leaves to
go to her grandma's house and
unbeknownst to her he immediately gets
killed in a drive fight in a drive-by
some guys [__] drive by him and just
[__] like him until later later right
yeah like when she calls no
and that was like really sad yeah yeah
he was like the only only guy that was
nice to her he's trying to help her I
mean he was he's in gang and stuff yeah
yeah but he was uh he was kind of a
[__]
what it was a good way to put it he was
kind of a [__] innocent type of dude
he was just he didn't know any better he
was just trying to help her yeah yeah I
mean freaking and his enemies got him
[__] laid him out
but yeah I mean it's just so many cute
like Reese Witherspoon is just so
[__] cute in this because she is just
like I said she is trashy as [__] yeah
and she just says the most [__] up
[__] yeah she's real racist even though
she had a black boyfriend is all these
[__] right well although she was she
yeah she did call that cop the n-word
yeah but she just said that like later
on after they kind of pulled her out
yeah she just said she did it like to
make it mad yeah but her mom was like
that though too yeah yeah she was
tricking the black guys and then [__]
insulting them at the same time when
they didn't [__] take the bait yeah
that's right but yeah so yeah this poor
kid she didn't really have a chance or
anything like that but I think that I
liked the way that they kind of
you know like I said it's kind of a
satire
um
and the fact that Kiefer Sutherland is
this very very upstanding you know led
to be live reasonably wealthy dude his
wife actually who's like this socialite
whose name is Mimi is played by Brooke
Shields and she's actually great in that
role she is a mega [__]
and but she doesn't know that he's a
serial killer so after
um Reese Witherspoon like [__] him up
because I had totally forgotten like I
said I thought the whole movie was like
cat and mouse game like uh between him
and her like she gets picked up and he's
just keep like after and stuff like that
but no like spoiler alert a third of the
way through the movie she shoots his ass
like she is absolutely not having it
like as soon as because he tries he
pretends like he's nice and he's trying
to get her to like open up about all
this
um all of her traumatic childhood and
everything like that but like as it's
going on you can tell that he's just
getting her to say this [__] because
he's getting off on it yeah and then he
straight up implies that he's gonna kill
her and then have sex with her dead body
yeah and then she gets super super
offended like she gets really really mad
he does that to other people so he he
was gonna do that right and uh but I
like the character
she's [__] crazy as [__] she's
extremely [__] trashy
um but she's she's
cute and she's [__] real Brave real
Brave real tough
makes it through a lot of [__] she has
some anger issues let's put it that way
yeah
a lot of it was just she had good
survival instincts a lot of it was
[__] kind of like dumb luck and faith
you know Jesus watching out for and
stuff like that you just got to see it
you know I mean because after she shoots
Kiefer Sutherland like she's like a
comet goes across this guy or something
she she takes that as like God saying
that that was okay and that was like
what she was supposed to do yeah yeah
but that's just part of the fight and
then she turns up at a diner and she's
like covered with blood yeah it doesn't
even wash it off and she's just like
sitting there looking at the menu and
like ordering [__] and everybody's
staring at her and she's like oh I must
look a fright yeah y'all got a washroom
yeah you know what I mean she just goes
in there and then there's like that
[__] scene where she goes to the um
after they well they put her in juvie
they're actually gonna try her as an
adult because like I said she shoots the
[__] out of Bob but he survives but he's
all [__] up like his head shots and
everything yeah like his face his face
is all um like deformed and he can't
like he's like a um paraplegic
quadriplegic so he's like in a in a
wheelchair and stuff and um although I
think he gets better like later on
because he's kind of walking later but
he's still kind of [__] up looking
it's the only thing it's the only
problem I have over the movie
she the pistol that the boyfriend gave
her if I recall correctly was a [__]
Taurus pt-92 which is a Beretta copy
nine millimeter
and the first thing she does is it
didn't I mean she shot him right in the
neck and basically Point Blank maybe
yeah like right yeah because she was
right behind him in the car and she just
went Papa even if that was Full Metal
Jacket bullet would which is not as
damaging as say hollow points
no you wouldn't survive that I shot that
close and right through the Meat part of
the neck and then he shot him a couple
times in the back
when he was running and then later
walked up and [__] dumb checked him
from the back of his head and I think it
came out this front eye didn't it it
came out his eye yeah yeah and yeah
that's kind of going underneath the
brain case but still it's just it's just
too much trauma but like I said the
whole movie is supposed to be like over
the top right and like and you know
because I'm sitting there thinking like
the whole movie because I had totally
forgotten I thought the whole movie was
like the two of them and then then I was
like holy [__] she just [__] shot him
and it's only like a third of the way
through like I thought like so obviously
like he had to live but like I said he
was all [__] up and the fact that he
was this upstanding citizen who he was
married he had this really nice house
and nobody knew he was he was the I the
I-5 killer I think was what they called
him and nobody knew that he was that and
he was also like a necrophile and
everything yeah and he was um they uh
they implied that he was into child
prawn as well yeah Kitty prawns but um
but yeah because when they did the shed
and everything so I thought it was good
the way they kind of went into and I
mean obviously Reese Witherspoon's
character she's Vanessa she's not
helping her case because she's just as
soon as they put her somewhere she just
beats the [__] out of people she just
like talks [__] [__] at people she
like absolutely just gives no [__] so
so it was very easy for Bob the serial
killer and his prissy ass wife to paint
themselves as the victim yeah and like
and her oh she was just some crazy [__]
that you know carjacked me and took my
money because she did take his money
like after she thought he was dead she's
not bad though she's just um
kind of like animalistic it's just yeah
it's just fight or flight right you know
she's captured well [__] I gotta get out
of here you know just trying to get out
of there any way she can you know and
then as soon as she discovered that he
was the I5 killer she she figured she
was justified in killing him because
he'll go kill somebody right she and she
says to the cop later on she's like you
know he would have just gone and picked
up some other girl and that would be my
fault yeah you know what I mean so yeah
so she thought she was gonna take him
out which you know was absolutely the
right thing to do it's just
unfortunately he survived it you know
what I mean because maybe he had like a
titanium plate just a prison or
something
Hispanic girl tries to [__] lean on
her first thing she shows up into them
on the tear
and uh she instantly turns around just
like attacks a girl
no no hesitation which that's the right
answer
she even pulled the the receiver the
phone off yeah
but see that but see the invitation then
later on that girl her name was uh
mosquito by the way yeah uh she actually
helped her yeah they became friends
Escape like that because that was it was
like a respect thing yeah so but like I
said she she did some not so great [__]
like the whole like killing that dude
obviously very Justified the cops didn't
see it that way because they didn't know
that he was the I5 killer until later
um because they didn't even really
bother
looking into her story I feel like
because she had such a long rap sheet so
they were kind of like oh well she's
obviously just like a [__] trash
person well that's what that's what um
Kiefer Sutherland called her a garbage
person yeah and that's like who he was
targeting so he was kind of one of those
Mission oriented killers that goes
around like picking up people that he
thinks are like disposable garbage
people yeah and he's like punishing them
yeah that's what uh oh what's his name
called Bottom Feeders yeah what was his
name um
hey Ted buddy Ted Bundy Ted Bundy called
uh Gary Ridgeway a bottom feeder yeah
he's just killing hookers uh he's got no
Style no taste you know because even
among cereals yes there's like a
hierarchy yeah which is really fun Bundy
was proud that he only went after good
girls
yeah
you're you're a real prize yeah
motherfucker's dead though yeah uh Camp
guy says Giant Truck Stop gas stations
can be dangerous for a lot lizards oh
absolutely I've heard that a lot of
serial killers are truck drivers yeah I
mean obviously not all truck drivers are
serial killers but a lot of serial
killers do tend to be truck drivers it
will because it's a it's a profession
that attracts that would attract that
type of person like if you were looking
to always moving around yeah yeah and
you know and you got a truck you got a
rolling thing that you can have people
in and nobody will see you and all that
kind of [__] Camp guy also said strange
new case just got arrested and started
in Greenville South Carolina involves a
girl her ex her kid her new fiance and
some dogs from the vet practice where
she works I'll try to find out the names
for y'all right now
yeah well I guess we'll find out yeah uh
let me see dude Kevin Smith said hey Tom
and Jenny I remember this movie it was
back when I had a huge crush on Reese
Witherspoon yeah she's super cute in
this I don't even know how old
she's playing a 15 or 16 year old and I
bought it I think she might have been
more like 19 or 20. yeah because I'm
pretty sure this was before Legally
Blonde when did Legally Blonde come out
98 I want to say maybe so that was a
couple years before that
um Zach says random but y'all seen the
species movies I've seen the first one I
saw the second one earlier oh my God it
was stupid but so much fun oh Beth house
Zachary
he said he was he had an appointment out
of the cooties yeah
oh tangling Packer yeah
oh my God yeah that's what happens when
you say the stuff in the chat like you
need to go visit streammates
the chlorine won't save you hahaha
yeah murder Hornet commented up here I
hate to tell you this time but Jenny is
cheating on you I've seen the video yeah
[Laughter]
yeah she cheats with you the Watcher
whoever was watching that video she's
cheating with you I'm gonna have to do
another one like that yeah with better
lighting and better angles yeah but you
know I can't believe
we were watching that video It's Only
from a couple minutes a couple of months
ago how much weight you've lost in that
amount of time yeah I lost 20 pounds
yeah I didn't notice it until I saw the
videos like what
man yeah okay you're still cute but yeah
you could definitely see
that you've gotten thinner
yeah I think I've lost about 20 pounds
yeah but I I shot that in May yeah first
or second week of May yeah so it was a
couple months ago yeah you had some more
meat on you then yeah yeah
it's still good that face is cute it's
cute yeah I mean he does but
I like it either way it's all right
thanks Tom yeah Hugo says you look good
now though yeah yeah I do too yeah we
did we need to make some more stuff we
got our mini vids up yeah finally
so we have I think we have 10 videos up
there yeah 10 videos at the moment yep
and I'm gonna have and I have you know
some days off coming up I have to work
tomorrow and Wednesday but then I have
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday Monday
off so we're gonna
make some more videos and we're gonna
stream and stuff too yeah we streamed uh
was it yesterday yesterday and yesterday
yesterday for like an hour 45 minutes
that first hour we made like I think we
took home almost 50 bucks I think we
made 45 dollars something like that just
in like an hour yeah yeah it's like
those dudes turn the camera on bed
hurry up those dudes are [__]
shredded
one dude would have could have competed
in ifpb men's fitness
that's that's what he looked like and he
put on a whole show that other people
would [__] pay to see he's in there
doing [__] one arm push-ups where
he's jerking it
giving me the thumbs up
[Laughter]
that shit's [__] funny man
we could do like a whole [__] other
stuff just like talking you're talking
about yeah just because my build I'm
attracting these Gym Rats that [__]
try to outdo me or they want you know
they'd want to show off yeah they want
to show off
had one dude come in there [__] his
name was Viking or something or other
and something something Viking yeah and
he goes I got an 11 inch dick like that
and we're like yeah [__] you're
gonna have to [__] prove that because
if you come in and say that yeah he
comes well [__] man he [__] went
exclusive and turned his camera on and
sure enough that [__] was like
all right fair play yeah I was like you
got it
and he did look like a viking I think it
was like six feet tall
big dude man big dude and [__] for
you guys who know porn if you know who
[__]
oh diesel is what's his name uh Shane
Diesel he made Shane Diesel look small
so yeah it was [__] I saluted that
[__] looking good yeah yeah because
Tom's just like all right yeah man you
won that cup
like a 40 ounce [__] beer
it was yeah yeah
it was amazing he wasn't dude that dude
should have been in porn
yeah I mean not everybody so the other
guy the other guy should have been born
yeah well yeah like I said like this cup
they probably could have had their own
streaming yeah they could have been
streaming and could have instead of just
like paying to watch us yeah yeah you
know we they paid us to put on a show
for us
yeah I mean yeah one dude he put on
horses yeah yeah I mean we were too but
yeah
you spent over a hundred dollars yeah I
think he did
I think he did he was on for a while 15
minutes yeah
at 5.99 a minute
I mean I don't know yeah I don't know if
you got a block because you can buy
blocks and you get like a DC uh what do
you call it a discount but I'm not yeah
he may have bought a 15 so I think he
bought a 15 minute block yeah probably
did I mean you still got to pay for it
but it's not as much as if you paid yeah
I think you get like a dollar off right
something like that Hugo said you guys
should watch uh California with a K yeah
I've seen that 1993 with Brad Pitt
they're visiting all serial killer sites
it's pretty good yeah that's another one
that I've been wanting to revisit
because I remember seeing that back in
the 90s as well and uh and really liking
that one so I might get around to that
one uh you know just eventually was I
kind of want to think was um
[__] man
was Christian Slater in that or am I
thinking of something else
I know Christian Slater was in like
every movie around that time period
like after Heather's came out it was
just kind of like then he was in Pump Up
the Volume and [__] we never did you
Pump Up the Volume did we that was a
great [__] movie too I love that
movie
Hugo said nasal whistle is prominent
tonight
oh because you're I guess because you're
like sniffling is that what it is or
maybe
um
if you guys had just watched Sympathy
for the Devil with Nicholas Cage it was
interesting man Nicholas Cage is in
everything every time I scroll through
any streaming service I'm like every
third movie has Nicholas Cage in it I'm
like when does the dude sleep I don't
know uh Camp guy said amazing Jenny
congrats thank you about oh about losing
the weight yeah that's awesome my wife
has been following a diet and exercising
lately lost five or ten pounds at age
59. yeah it is much harder when you're a
little bit older but and like I said I'm
I have a um it's just a genetic
propensity to put weight on so I really
have to
watch it like I really have to do
calorie restriction
um you know I just can't overeat and I
especially can't now that I'm
you know old because if I ate what I
wanted to eat all the time I would be
like 500 pounds for real hormone
replacement that's another key well that
works too yeah yeah that also helps but
like I said I don't all I ate today I
ate my little I ate my little can of
tuna salad for lunch I think that's 200
calories and then when I got home you
made
Curry like Thai curry but it was
actually like almost all vegetables it
was just vegetables and chicken and just
like a kind of a thin broth and it's
really really good yeah coconut broth
yeah like a coconut broth like it had
tomatoes and peppers and yeah onions
it's healthy yeah it was really yeah it
was yummy actually it was really really
good you hadn't made that in a while
um yeah the guy from the X-Files is in
California too but what but it wasn't
was was Christian Slater in it though
because why am I thinking Christian
Slater was in that movie
I don't know I have to look it up I
remember seeing it and I remember liking
it but I saw so many movies in the
[__] 90s because we were always
renting them because you know I grew up
in Daytona there was like nothing to do
like we didn't have a lot of money and I
didn't have a car and [__] like that so
most of the time we just went to [__]
Blockbuster and rented like three or
four movies and got some snacks and just
like sat around watching them so I think
that's probably when I first saw freeway
as well but I don't I don't know I I was
watching um there do seem to be like a
lot of other YouTube uh reviews of
freeway including off the shelf reviews
it's these two British guys and they're
really funny because they just kind of
do like kind of an off-the-cuff kind of
[__] like we do like usually you have a
couple drinks and their shit's usually
like 40 50 minutes long where they just
kind of like sit around talking about
the movie
kind of going off on tangents and stuff
and I just watched the one that they did
about
uh about this movie and they ended up
they said when they first started
watching it they weren't sure they were
gonna like it or not because they
thought Reese Witherspoon's character
was like really annoying like her voice
was really annoying which I get that but
then like at the end like as it went on
they ended up like really really liking
it but like I said you have to approach
it
knowing that it's supposed to be funny
like it's a black comedy because I don't
know if you went into it thinking it was
going to be like a series like a
thriller then you might be like what the
[__] am I even watching because it's
really like it's tonally it's very very
weird it's not like a thriller at all
her accent was actually accurate but not
for Texas it was accurate more for like
Kentucky well like I said the the story
took place in California yeah but I
don't remember where she was supposed to
be from Texas yeah well I mean Reese
Witherspoon that's actually her her
actual accent but she just exaggerated
it okay
um and I don't actually remember where
she's from originally but she you know
yeah I just saw something where she said
you know that's her actual voice but she
just like exaggerated it quite a bit
Yeah like when I'm around my dad all of
a sudden you just start drifting into a
[__] thicker and thicker Mississippi
Delta yeah if you listen to Tom like
talking to his dad on the phone
notice that he's like talking more and
more Southern yeah
said she's from Alabama yeah okay
okay that makes sense so yeah in Alabama
I'd be up around where you'd up around
Kentucky at that area yeah yeah and she
yeah she's so she has a very very thick
southern accent in this but it's kind of
like her real voice
oh Camp guy said I think she's from
Alabama all right so I don't know but uh
but yeah so I like I said it's on um to
be and I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
the sequel is on there too I saw the
sequel back in the 90s I think Jennifer
Tilly is in it like I said there's none
of the same actors but I've heard it's
like good I saw it a long time ago but I
don't but literally do not remember a
single thing about it
um I don't know so maybe I'll do that
like eventually like watch it but I got
distracted last night because
um after I watched that
I was like scrolling through 2B and I
realized that 2B has a whole a veritable
smorgasbord
of old classic horror movies like from
the 20s and 30s and 40s they have a [__]
ton of them so we ended up watching the
original Nosferatu from 1922. yeah and
then we ended up watching the original
one of the original like Flash Gordon
yes cereal ship or something yeah like
from
1933. it wasn't a cereal it was a movie
yeah it was only like an hour long
though no that was more than that it was
an hour and it was eight minutes no it
was an hour and three minutes okay yeah
it was only an hour long yeah real
fast-paced it's basically real similar
to the movie
to The Flash Gordon movie The Dino De
Laurentiis one it's that same basic
that pretty much yeah
but yeah so there was that but yeah they
also had like um that white zombie and
they had like all because I was kind of
like oh I kind of want to watch White
Zombie too but then it was getting kind
of late so I didn't but flash Gordman
Buster crab though
that [__] is so dumbed down I mean it's
[__] dumb we had a good time watching
it's just fun yeah it's just fun to
watch
um it's constant action and silly action
and uh hot babes hot babes
twenties I think it's 20s I thought it
was 1930s 30s yeah but it might have
been earlier I thought a lot of sexual
undertones in it yeah big time yeah yeah
I mean Ming's daughter was just trying
to jump on that he is mine you know all
that kind of [__] yeah he's trying to
jump on that dick she wants him to be
her sex sleep yeah well she gives him
that potion too love potions and they
try to get Ming tries to marry Dale
because they were using some kind of
mind control device on her for a bit
didn't they yeah remember yeah it was
like it was like a thing like a neon
light and like if you stared at it then
it like controlled your mind yeah it's
like his uh [__] high-tech roofie
yeah yeah like drugs would probably be a
lot cheaper they used Rays for
everything the truth Rey the invisible
race it's the future man you just use a
ray to do it yeah get that death ray get
the roofie Ray yeah get the rape Ray
yeah they take iguanas and [__] glued
a bunch of spikes on them so much back
then I just blew them up they did I
don't know if they killed them I don't
think they did but they they said apart
I suspect they might have I don't know I
think they just because they didn't
really show the aftermath they just
showed a firecracker go off next door
they were like hey what the [__]
poor little lizards well yeah they did
that a lot like going into the 50s like
those bird eye Gordon movies and stuff
like that where they would always be
like oh we're going to Dinosaur Island
and then they would take like an iguana
because I guess people didn't really see
iguana like an iguana or a little
monitor lizard or something like that
and they [__] yeah they would like
glue like cardboard [__] spines to
their backs like Jesus Christ cruelty to
animals they didn't give a [__] they're
like yeah make them fight yeah and it
comes I did see a few from I think the
50s that um were actually one did Kill
the other one so it was like a lizard
snuffed movie yeah I saw I have a hard
time watching that
I love lizards I really I really like
the lizards and I think that's shitty I
mean I know they would have been dead
now anyway but I'm just saying that it's
like I don't really like they just
looked at it those were things that you
bought from the pet store and a lot of
other people ate them and [__] so you
know I know but it's just kind of like
I'm kind of glad that people don't
really do that so much anymore because I
kind of feel like back then it was so
freewheeling and they're just like
that's just an animal who gives a [__]
we can kill each other for the movie
we'll get more they were killing sharks
for movies yeah but if you want like if
you have a shutter there's a great they
just put a documentary on there called
Shark exploitation and it's all about
like all the [__] shark but which I
knew there was a lot of shark movies I
didn't realize how many shark movies
there were and I actually didn't realize
how far back it went you know what I
mean like because they had shark movies
like back in the [__] 20s right like
that weren't super super like shark
Focus but they still had like sharks in
them and stuff so they had that and
there was
um yeah there were like a couple of
movies where they did like kill actual
sharks like in in the movie
so people complain about a Cannibal
Holocaust but like other movie makers
were doing that [__] too and that is not
cool not cool at all but yeah they did
like a big long thing about Jaws and
about Peter benchley like they had a big
long interview with that Peter
benchley's uh Widow and she was talking
about how bad Peter eventually felt like
after the book came out and then after
the movie came out and so like everybody
was like oh sharks are evil so then like
everybody started like killing them you
know what I mean like they started all
of these
tournaments where it's like who can kill
the biggest shark and it's like they're
a menace to the Sea and so Peter
eventually felt really bad so like a lot
of his later life was devoted to kind of
conservation like ocean conservation
because he felt so shitty that he had
been kind of responsible for everybody
killing the Sharks and [__] like that
but yeah it's really good and it talked
all about
um you know obviously it talked about
like the more recent stuff it even
mentioned Ouija shark which we taught
which was a terrible movie but like
which we talked about Sharktopus and
Sharknado and all that kind of stuff but
yeah it was a lot of fun but that's it's
on uh shutter yeah sharks are freaking
lasers on their heads they did mention
that in there too it's very thorough I
mean they cover a lot of stuff in there
uh those movies with giant iguanas are
awesome yeah I mean but like I said they
did kind of make him fight with one
another I think a couple of ones that I
saw look like they were actually like
hurting each other and I was kind of
upset about it because I used to have a
pet iguana and I used to have a pet
Gekko also so I I actually quite like
lizards all right so we ready to wrap it
up yep all right so
Wednesday night show which hopefully you
can join us for that
um we are going to be talking about
people who faked their own kidnappings
so I'm just gonna do I haven't decided
which ones I'm gonna focus on I'm not
gonna talk about Sherry papini because
we already did a show about her uh like
on a slightly different topic because
she's one of the most famous ones I
faked her own kidnapping but there are
some other
Crazy Ones do they have that recent one
where the girl disappeared and when she
came back she claimed to have been
chained up by two other girls and that
they branded her or something that was
Cherry papini yeah yeah okay but we did
a show about her before yeah was running
two
no she faked it she faked it okay she
faked it she was basically she went and
stayed with her ex-boyfriend okay and he
for whatever reason
um went along with it and like helped
her she told him that her husband was
beating on her and she was trying to get
away from him and I guess at escalate
because she was gone for a while like
for several weeks or a month or
something like that and then see so she
goes to the ex-boyfriend's house and is
like yeah my my husband's beating me up
and I'm trying to get away from him and
stuff but then like as time went on
she's like hey can you brand me and he
just he did it yeah what do you browned
her with I don't know yeah it was like
you I couldn't really read it but it was
like on the back of her shoulder you
don't remember what it was no because I
saw like part of it and she said some
Mexican cartel girls tried to sell her
or something yeah she was trying to
imply that she was going to be traffic
yeah
but yeah they found out later that she
was yeah and the cops were kind of full
of crap yeah I mean they believed her at
first but then like her story didn't
really yeah yeah but yeah so I I've kind
of been going through like just lists of
different people that did this stuff and
it's like some of them are kind of funny
because they did it for like really
stupid reasons so it's like all right
we'll do that so I want to get into some
of that too but I mean it's kind of not
funny because you're using a lot of law
enforcement resources that could be used
on like actual crimes
um on your [__] like especially like
oh I'm gonna pretend I got kidnapped
because I got an F on my report card or
some [__] like that you know meanwhile
people are getting murdered over here so
and a lot of times they do actually make
them pay
for how much time they wasted on that
[__] why because Sherry papini I
think she got some prison time and she
did yeah I think well it wasn't a long
time I think it was just 18 months and
they made her pay
um I think she had to pay 300 000 back
or something like that because of all
the time that she wasted and [__] like
that so don't fake your own kidnapping
people I mean it's probably a really
really dumb thing to do and especially
for some of the reasons that these
people [__] do it which are
pretty universally pretty stupid
so yeah all right so that's what uh
Wednesday night show is going to be so
hopefully you guys can join us for that
it'll be at 7 30 p.m Eastern Standard
Time as usual and uh hopefully we can go
on a little bit longer than usual
because I'll be off the next day so I
don't have to worry about like going to
bed early and [__] like that
so we can uh have a good time with it
because it's you know it's crime but
it's not nobody got killed so it's it's
not a horribly Grim subject all right so
thanks everybody for dropping by and
hanging out with us this Monday evening
we'll see you guys again on Wednesday
good night